i don't give a [ __ ] here hey arty the
fat ass
you're gonna be a great chef but get the
[ __ ] off the football field you suck
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
good morning good morning thanks for
coming thanks for having me yeah to your
place
yes yeah really cool it's really far
from montclair new jersey though i'm
aware yeah
but uh fred i always get excited when
somebody gets transferred from hudson
yards to here and lives in jersey
we find out their true grit definitely
first of all i just heard about your new
show
and it sounds unbelievable unbelievable
so
tell us how trash talk came and you
don't really need the cash
i don't think so no i explained to you
what drives my entire saturday to make
613 i'm not sure if there's any place
i'm happier
in the world than when i am actively
garage sailing in new jersey
at 8 13 in the morning on a saturday i
love garage sale
here's what's really driving me an
enormous amount of people follow me
who disproportionately are affected by
making a hundred to five hundred dollars
more a month like that means
something for real all of my homies and
contemporaries are telling these people
to build the next facebook
i'm practical i know that anybody who's
listening right now who genuinely needs
an extra hundred bucks a week the
easiest and i don't use by the way i
hate the word easy
the easiest way to make 100 bucks extra
a week
is to go to thrift stores goodwill
garage sales
buy things and sell them on ebay offer
up
just try it for a little while see if
you can do it i do think that the
average
skilled person after a couple months
gets to 20
or 30 bucks an hour but when it comes to
sports
and especially when you're a kid i mean
being a mom that watched my kids in all
the different sports
and yes if you get fourth place and
fifth whatever place
it's it's a little bit of a confidence
builder it's like okay i'm out of here
okay i'm bobby you have to bobby there's
some like you know chubby fat kid who's
like barry who's naked
who needs to understand yo chubby fat
kid you're not gonna be a professional
[ __ ] athlete
go be a great [ __ ] heart you're great
i don't give a [ __ ]
hey hardy the fat ass you're gonna be a
great chef
but get the [ __ ] off the football field
you suck but i just think everyone's
good at something
that's right so get off the [ __ ]
football field but guess what
mommy bobby over here is tricking you
and making you think you might be okay
no yes his microphone louder than mine
or does he just talk louder i'm trying
to figure out just out here
like you're a [ __ ] gangster winner
and you this is why
this is what i'm worried about bobby
there's a reason
that people are struggling mentally and
i'm telling you
everybody wants to blame social media
it's [ __ ] it's parents creating fake
environments for children
we're building zoo animals it means when
you take a tiger from the bronx zoo and
you put it in the actual jungle
he [ __ ] or she dies in one second
because they've
not grown up in the actual environment
you take kids
who [ __ ] think they're good at
baseball because in montclair up until
[ __ ] 12th grade
everybody's [ __ ] good and then you
actually go and play baseball and you
get
[ __ ] struck out 900 times in a row
you go back to your dorm room and start
doing [ __ ] cocaine
oh come on gary it doesn't work like
that that's exactly it does not my
whoa listen listen you look at the kids
faces did you play baseball
no football okay he did [ __ ] cocaine
like
no if you're not good at football and
you love the sport so go work for the
team
like there's ways to take your passion
keep building no but it's true i mean i
watched my kids i had a i had a
you know pro golfer i had you know i had
guys kids that were good at different
things and then they weren't anymore you
know they entered high school
you know they were on traveling soccer
and baseball their entire careers
until they went to high school they
realized they're not going to make it
and they didn't so they moved on that's
fine and listen a lot of people don't
move on
yeah and and creating fake environments
is an issue that needs to be talked
about
much more fake environments don't be
don't doesn't mean
like mean it means just don't create
delusion so you give advice
all the time if there's one thing you
could tell people right now to do
right now that will change the course of
their life one thing
communicate the poison that's in their
head to the person that needs to hear it
[Music]
hello how are you
hey man good to see you it's a pleasure
thanks for being here
i want you to be super selfish and ask
the exact question that you want because
that's what we're here for that's what
my part is about and
it's been fun when you know didn't know
how that would play out but it's
you know it's remarkable obviously many
very different businesses different life
cycles but
it's amazing how there's always
something to take from somebody else's
questions so
i'm glad you guys are here two hours
later thank you guys
guys great to see you again bro thank
you so
much guys take care take care of course
hello you are on the ask garyvee
show with asher warrior
oh my goodness no way this is so
trillion crazy one you could have it a
tree it would suck if i was tree
trees can't do anything gratitude
got it
yo
we need more of that kind of stuff
and his name is john cena
bye talk to you soon thank you
[Music]
what do you think about the agents and
stuff like that i think if you want to
like if you're like
like like this is how i think the
world's crazy now like what up like you
know when i go on stage i'm like this is
the best year to ever be alive like
people are like ah trump and i i
understand it they're not wrong
there's plenty of [ __ ] up [ __ ] you
made a [ __ ] video on a
like you know what i mean like people
don't get it like like that's not how it
went down
like you know like like i'm old like you
used to have to get
you had to move to [ __ ] hollywood
wait tables and be the one black dude
they picked out of
everyone there yeah it's real wild and
if you like if you're a youngster
you don't have context you don't know
but like
i'm i got it real good because i'm old
enough to know but young enough to still
want to do something about it
and then you got people that are like
this is why 80 year olds are he's
[ __ ] you know
so couple things if you really want to
have like a netflix special
or like straight up you're like [ __ ] it
i want to make like
friday you need a [ __ ] agent
okay what do you think that they bring
they bring i guess the production into
they're gatekeepers they don't bring
anything
but the keys right
they put him together with somebody who
really knows how to make movies
they hit it off and they make a [ __ ]
you know beverly hills cop
let's go right like it's just kind of
like that
it's just kind of crazy like that if
that's what you want to do
if you want to do like that's what's
crazy about music
how far you can now go in film you can't
like nobody
you can't point me to the movie that's
like the big blockbuster on youtube yet
i believe that will happen yeah i
believe the same way netflix happened i
believe like
you could wait and make your own comedy
raise money
make something amazing and in 12 15
years i think
what netflix is is gonna be long tail
there'll be more of them things like
them the way internet
works right like like even the way
people watch the [ __ ] you know i don't
know
but like i'm obsessed with garage
sailing people are watching my [ __ ]
you know people are taking pictures of
them watching it they're watching it on
their main tv because everybody now
knows how to put youtube from the phone
to the team you know like grandma
doesn't but you do
and and so like when that happens
well then let's go like you can do your
own stand-up special
rent out a [ __ ] place have people
come film it and you can do your own
raw and you've got a big enough audience
like i paid 3.99 for you
you know that kind of [ __ ] so it's all
coming
the problem is your moments now yeah
exactly
right so you have to give up some of the
money
right to like continue it if that's what
you want to do
or you keep building momentum you keep
you know i'm watching you like you keep
trying it like what's great about being
creative
is you could think of something tomorrow
post it
and you got a shot and and i do think
this
i do think if you have a second meme of
real scale
it puts you in a totally different place
i would really give a [ __ ] about being
strategic about your next move
but i wouldn't be crippled by it either
you don't need to like if you put too
much pressure that i gotta nail this
next thing
you're gonna get in the wrong mindset
you need to be thoughtful
but you need to not overthink your
creativity it's how you got here in the
first place
yeah just doing regular [ __ ] just doing
regular [ __ ] that's a real good way to
put it
would you employ your friend over
outside of
always i love employing friends but
and since i was always top dog i've
always told friends i'll fire you i
swear because i'll help you get a job
better
but you can't [ __ ] up the thing and like
you can't be entitled
and like i'm a human and i may be wrong
like boy i may decide that boyd's better
than drock i may be wrong
but this is my [ __ ] you can go do your
[ __ ]
so if you want to be employed here i'm
going to try my best i got love i want
to all die
together but yeah i mean we started this
company with like seven friends
i took my assistant from wine library
the only person and it was like eight
six of aj's friends and we've
started cool
[Music]
thank you for having us this is amazing
hi all right nice to meet you matt a lot
of people get fearful of like actually
going where they need to go
because they got success somewhere else
it's the biggest mistake
authenticity always wins 100 is
you love garage sales more than
breathing are you serious
yes what are you going to sell me right
now bro what do you want i got all sorts
of [ __ ]
i don't know let's do some business
signed album of course i want to know
i think if we did a national commercial
with you
that leaned into your sex appeal but in
a clever way
it would it would explode so i just have
to i haven't
i i have the concept that's my concept
i think it will lean in it will be very
good for you because it will like
it's almost like a big company saying
like got it
it will work i just now have to think
about the brand
and the creative idea that's clever to
lean into it but it will [ __ ] work
hey guys it's danielle snyder with no
filter this is episode
six with my favorite gary that's not my
dad
that's right what up gary vaynerchuk
things are amazing
congrats on all the mitzvahs in your
life and i'm super excited to be here
what is the worst pitch that's ever come
to you where you were just like
actually can i pull out my like
recording device to record that oh it's
funny
it's amazing that nothing populated on
the flip side
almost all of them we live in a
completely delusional world
where people think their idea is worth
seven million dollars but how much is it
really the idea versus the person behind
the idea that's gonna morph it into
whatever
you know it's the person behind it right
100
is there anything else we wanted to ask
that we didn't ask yet kanye west
what what are your thoughts on kanye
west happy to answer what are your
thoughts on kanye west sydney sent me
some questions
i didn't know i don't i don't know what
are your thoughts on con this is super
easy for me um
you know kanye's credit get asked this a
lot and it's super easy for me to answer
does he bother you
no uh do you want him to vote i want
every single person on earth to follow
right i don't have here's what i would
say
kanye and i share and taylor swift and
many others
zucks have a very similar skill set
which is we
understand human behavior and what
garners attention
and we all attention arbitrage that's
right and we all do it very very
very differently the truth is i don't
know so i'll explain
all i know about kanye is the blips like
i don't follow him i don't consume his
content
i haven't heard any of his last three
albums because he [ __ ] put on title
like uh so i don't know what's going on
musically at all
i don't the the it's a very easy answer
for me i don't
know right like i don't know what he's
truly thinking
i don't think he's trolling like
everyone who's like he's just doing this
for attention
doesn't intuitively i don't think so um
but you know like what's super
interesting is the things he brings up
that i've hit
by accident there's a lot of intriguing
thought in the process of what he's
doing
and so it's super interesting to watch
from afar
but i haven't i've almost purposely not
allowed myself to dig in deep enough
to form an educated opinion a
because i don't dig into anything like
that content-wise
so for example you'll appreciate this
this is actually how my brain works
my opinions on kanye are predicated on
the hundreds of thousands of
comments on about kanye more than what
kanye's actually doing
my big move normally when something hits
my zeitgeist
uh stranger things is a big show oh
weird okay i'll go
i'll go to stranger things instagram or
youtube or twitter
but i won't see what they're doing i'll
read everything that people have to say
about it
i literally read i want to actually i've
been throwing around a lot of numbers i
want to nail it
man i read a lot i've read thousands of
comments about cardi b
before i allowed myself to even listen
to a single song and
i love the way she story tells um but
uh but i uh but it was it was i
really like consuming people's reactions
more than the content that sparks the
reaction
i really do i like that's why i think
i'm good at america
i really understand america because i
consume america's
reactions to everything
[Music]
you